JOANNA SMITH: Hi.
I'm Joanna Smith,
and today, we're
looking at how to keep
your employees connected
and engaged--
even when they can't
be in the office.
Co-workers and teams are
able to stay connected
while working remotely
thanks to tools
like collaborative documents,
video meetings, and team chat
rooms.
On a larger scale,
enabling employees
to feel connected across teams
and to the company as a whole
can be a challenge.
One tactic that's
especially effective
here is to host a
virtual all-hands.
An all-hands meeting is
unique in its ability
to bring an
organization together
while ensuring that everyone
receives the same information.
In fact, a recent
study by igloo Software
found that 75% of remote
workers believe they miss out
on important information.
This can cause
operational issues,
and result in a
disengaged workforce.
But the logistics of running
an all-hands meeting remotely
may seem daunting.
Fortunately, you can
use G Suite and Google
Meet the host a virtual
all-hands for up to 100,000
employees, whether
they're working
from their home, office,
on the factory floor,
or out in the field.
Google Meet is our
enterprise-grade video
conferencing solution that takes
advantage of Google Cloud's
secure-by-design
infrastructure, and features
a number of proactive
counter-abuse protections
to help protect your data
and safeguard your privacy.
With Google Meet,
your video meetings
are secure, easy to join,
and offer helpful features,
like adaptive
layouts, so that you
can focus on what matters most.
Best of all, with G Suite, you
get so much more than meetings.
You can schedule
and join meetings
directly from Gmail
or Google Calendar,
easily present your screen
or collaborate on a document
during the meeting, and
securely record a meeting
and have it saved to Google
Drive to be shared later.
These same features
that make Google
Meet so effective as a
video conferencing solution
are what make it simple
and straightforward to host
a virtual all-hands meeting.
So let's take a look at how
that might come together.
First, we'll need to
create the calendar
event for our all-hands.
We'll select the time,
and then we can fill out
the initial
information, including
the event title and any details
we need in the description.
Then we need to add Google
Meet video conferencing, which
is as simple as a click.
Our all-hands is also going
to offer a livestream,
so to enable that, we'll want
to switch to the Event Details
page.
The option to add a livestream
is nested under the Google Meet
additional details view, and
all it takes is a single click.
Now, we can invite our
co-presenters and attendees,
and just like that, our virtual
all-hands has been scheduled.
A single Google Meet
video conference
supports up to 250 participants,
while a livestream supports up
to 100,000 viewers.
Depending on the size and
nature of your all-hands,
you may want to create
two separate events--
one that contains the Google
Video conference, to which you
only invite presenters,
and then a second event
for the view-only livestream,
where you can invite attendees.
Creating a view-only
event is a simple edit
on the initial event.
From the event details dialog,
click the three-dot menu
button, and select
Create View Only Event.
You can then invite
your attendees
and even modify the
event description,
if there is separate information
to share for the audience.
On the day of the
event, we'll want
to be sure that
everyone can join,
whether they're using
shared video conferencing
devices, the Google
Meet mobile app,
or watching the
view-only livestream
from any modern browser.
As the event
organizer, we'll want
to join early so that we can
turn on each of these features.
The livestream doesn't
begin automatically,
and needs to be started.
This allows organizers
to get set up
and test their presentations
without an accidental audience.
When everyone is ready,
we'll click Start Streaming.
We'll know the
livestream is active
based on the Live tag in
the corner of the screen.
If we want to make
this virtual all-hands
available after
the event, we can
choose to record the meeting.
To begin recording, select the
three dots in the bottom corner
to open a menu of
additional options.
There, we can click
Record Meeting,
and another red tag has
appeared in the upper corner,
to indicate that this
meeting is being recorded.
The recording will be
emailed to the organizer
after the livestream ends and
saved securely to Google Drive,
where can later be distributed
for on-demand viewing.
To stop recording
or streaming, simply
return to the Options menu.
Also, from this menu, we
can turn on live captions
to make the meeting
more inclusive.
Live captions and Google Meet
are powered by Google's speech
recognition
technology, not typed
by a human, which
helps ensure no one
outside your organization
is viewing private content.
During the all-hands,
each presenter
can easily participate, even if
they aren't in the same place.
When it's our turn
to present, we're
given the option to
share our entire screen,
a specific window, or
even a single Chrome
tab, which makes it easy to play
high-quality videos with audio.
And when we're done, we
simply stop presenting.
With these options,
Meet makes it
easy to have control of the
content you'd like to share.
With distributed teams,
it's especially important
to have a mechanism in
place for giving feedback.
After the all-hands ends, we'll
use Google Forms to quickly
create a simple survey.
We can customize the format,
randomize the questions,
and designate certain
questions as required,
so employees can
share their thoughts
on the event and content.
Because of the deep
integrations built into G Suite,
the survey responses
automatically
populate into a
Google Sheet where
we can view the raw responses,
or use the Explore feature
to get suggestions on pivot
tables or data visualizations.
The feedback form, along
with the recording,
presented slides,
and follow materials
can be shared across the
company using an internal portal
created with Google Sites.
This internal site provides
a quick and easy way
to keep everyone
on the same page,
and serves as an on-demand
reference for their content.
A site like this is
especially helpful
when onboarding new employees,
and it's easy to update,
so you can keep adding
additional content
as it becomes available.
And that is how you can
use G Suite and Google Meet
to host a virtual all-hands to
keep your employees connected
and engaged, even when they
can't be in the office.
If you aren't
already on G Suite,
we have a new way to help
you get started immediately.
With our new G Suite
Essentials offering,
teams and
organizations can start
collaborating using
the tools you've
seen here in hours, not weeks.
G Suite Essentials
includes Google Meet,
Drive, Docs, Sheets,
Slides, Forms, and Sites.
It's compatible with your
existing IT environment,
and there is no need to adopt
a new email or calendar system.
From now through September
30, teams and organizations
can use G Suite
Essentials at no cost,
including advanced
functionality,
like shared Drives,
meeting recordings,
and in-domain live streaming.
For existing G Suite
customers, we're
also enabling access to advanced
Meet functionality at no cost
through September 30.
This includes
in-domain livestreaming
for up to 100,000
people, the ability
to record meetings to
Drive, and larger meetings
for up to 250 people per call.
To learn more about G Suite,
visit gsuite.google.com.